(upbeat music)
♪ I'm comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ I'm comin' home now, right away ♪
♪ I'm sorry now I ever went away ♪
♪ Every night and day, I go and stay ♪
♪ I'm comin' home now ♪
♪ Come on home ♪
♪ Comin' home now, baby ♪
♪ You know I'm waiting here for you ♪
♪ I'm comin' home now, real soon ♪
♪ You've been gone ♪
♪ Comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ I don't know what I'm going through ♪
♪ I'm comin' home, I
know that I'm overdue ♪
♪ Since you went away ♪
♪ Expect me any day now, real soon ♪
♪ Comin' home now ♪
♪ Come on home ♪
♪ I'm comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ You know I'm praying every night ♪
♪ That everything is gonna be fine ♪
♪ Please come home ♪
♪ I'm comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ I want to feel you hold me tight ♪
♪ Expect to see me now, anytime ♪
♪ When I'm in your arms ♪
♪ When you're in my
arms, I'll be just fine ♪
♪ Hey, I'm comin' home ♪
♪ Come on home ♪
♪ Comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ I'm comin' home now,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Use the phone ♪
♪ I'm comin' home now ♪
♪ And let me hear you say ♪
♪ You're hearing what I'll say ♪
♪ That you're comin' home ♪
♪ And I will never go away ♪
♪ I'm comin' home ♪
♪ Comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ Oh, baby, say ♪
♪ You're comin' home ♪
♪ That's what I say ♪
♪ Something's wrong ♪
♪ I'm comin' home, baby, now ♪
♪ You ought to either write or phone ♪
♪ Baby, tell me you're ♪
♪ Baby, I'm for sure ♪
♪ I'm comin' home ♪
(audience cheering)